I'll become res - I am wearing an emo
wig and it looks like a black penis as
well especially if I start here it's
nice it's not nice okay anyway so
welcome back to south park the stick of
truth game of the year of every year
ever I'm gonna and going back to do
staff because it's [ __ ] a badass and
why am I wearing this stupid wig go away
alright so we go here is that it yeah
alright so now we have Kenny with us
instead about us I wish I could add both
cuz I think Kenny and bars are my
favorite side characters but yeah we
have any questions yet to the cafeteria
and help Craig escaped from detention I
like I like Craig I know Aloha
Kenny's dress up a Zelda and also love
how you bought bros pointed out that
Koopa means [ __ ] and in Polish that's
pretty funny man it's pretty [ __ ]
funny let's get to teleportation spy so
here we are at this but I don't want to
be seen with you
I wasn't even [ __ ] Club and Nook yet
I know you can hear South Park I'm sorry
card man laughs into this South Park
really I am stupid as [ __ ] excuse me but
school is out and those students allowed
on the premises until tomorrow at 7:30
a.m. oh but I'm sorry all right Kenny it
looks like we'll have to go you aren't
wait at school I must be punished but I
was gonna go anyway
Kenny SPO yes PO and Simoes friend I
swear if I was a sci-fi character I'd be
[ __ ] Kenny man
are you go [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] we're nuke EMFs go Kenny's bow oh
it's full of love I thought Dora oh it's
dead Kenny come officer down officer
down send backup what I repeat officer
down
Oh hallway monitor to the right hallway
oh god damn it
here they come they're gonna get you
Craig you're not getting out of
detention
I'll be out of here in 10 minutes oh yes
oh my god you're right yeah totally I
get what you're saying
what you want to have sex with a ginger
kid I like your thinking but we don't
have time for that all right all right
let's go again go cows football games oh
[ __ ] security chronic Al and gingers are
nifty man you can now cause explosions
by dragons shouting and on open flames
okay
Sandia fire and Faison hole oh shut up
here we go oh okay that took me forever
I don't know why yeah yeah all right
we're gonna get through this door yeah
you might as well give up because I've
hidden the key somewhere and you'll
never find it in my office
oh no more ginger kids goddamn Virginia
are you all right tell me if you're
ginger are you dangerous restricted
hallway
does it make any sense I was such
injuries were we're dangerous I always
knew I think would always have a sister
ready to stab you
yeah really good
now come on goddamn this [ __ ] is tough
but he's throwing up all out and he
Sheila's down maybe finishing Kenny for
the power of love that was awful
seriously oh [ __ ] he died from being
gross at that's wonderful now he's even
more dressed at ok what is this South
Park move sir Kim who's Anne I know that
voice will never surrender
Ariel watch Fernan home f & target body
icon left click to drag to your
companion I don't know where this kid is
ever like Kenny's gonna die I don't like
this go there Kenny don't die look I
wasn't ready for that
nice going Kenny I'll bet you're the
best heart you can take the brass key
from my cold dead man oh sorry Kenny Oh
does that affect them in there in there
and it yeah it does Holly I don't give a
[ __ ]
yeah but stab oh nice that it'll I like
that the abilities are cool but they
take so much time to make is not worth
it yeah go Kinney there's power of
families nice I gotta say the comment is
fun I I'm usually not much for a
turn-based RPGs but it's cool is that
the most elaborate one but what do you
expect honestly we don't give a [ __ ]
Kenny is so fabulous I swear to God
praise the Sun flora officer down
we're taking heavy casualties out here
damn it you hallway monitors need to
stop playing around
he's got the Brad key he's some kind of
Dragonborn now look this is detention
time not time to play Dungeons and
Dragons and besides he's never gonna get
inside here because to open the door you
need the gold key and the only way to
get those keys by getting the silver
cake okay which even if he has a brass
key he doesn't made it past the boss
level okay bobaloo brass key baby
high five rez all right let's get the
silver and the gold key then thanks for
[ __ ] telling us appreciate it all
right so we need to go to his office
first a lot of loot man oh no okay we
need to go here for her to my bag
all right there we go I guess here card
to Kate I got the memory of a goldfish
oh [ __ ] no for a guy what what happens
if I shoot that is do much there we go
god damn I'm [ __ ] so long oh my god
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
alright and now I can fart on it [ __ ]
you guys seriously there we go
holy [ __ ] I thought oh this is a
restricted hallway I'm gonna die anyway
finish intake are you okay man all right
shut up wherever it's matter with you Oh
whew so can he do something it said his
buddy command no he doesn't want to show
his status to him maybe we needed
butters is that it don't be afraid to
ask for help from your brain oh it is
okay oh I was a goner there were too
many of them they were too strong their
hair too red if you could take the
silver key and find the gold key you
could succeed where I failed free
becky's prisoners I would love to add
red hair okay don't don't don't be dumb
peas head cuz the game makes fun of
gingers you should be happy I would be
so happy if stuff like made fun of me so
I'm that's all I'm saying
but I'm Swedish and no one makes fun of
Swedish people because we're flawless in
every way possible I'm just saying it's
caught okay
now ginger freckles just for you hope
you're happy
now no I'm just kidding that's way too
ugly god damn it
now what jack up alright well we might
as well go all in huh I hope the gold
keys in there or else a quest for the
silver key has been all for nothing oh
okay we'll just AG this is Matty's lair
one wrong step and we could end up into
digit oh yeah but I mean we went so far
obviously we would always right there
all right shoot it yeah baby
the goal key no human has ever laid
hands on it before let's hope it holds
the power like the cafeteria door of
course it does
got yolk rat denies me goddamn I'm
ginger I'm ginger as my balls from space
when they've been in space I don't have
butter so question me okay let's go to
the cafeteria finally that's far enough
intruder Oh him
where's your Hall Pass
the first boss battle no I'll pass and
it's time to write you a referral holy
[ __ ] oh yeah that's the boat
good luck fighting the baby okay you
still think this is a game young moon
loved this game so much is authorized ah
so [ __ ] ready for this Christ maybe
not
I'm glad we have butters for this fight
though okay well I would say that he
probably has a lot of help
Shawn I'm talking look I'm junior - you
don't have to hurt me ginger steak
ticket out all right we're gonna have to
finish this guy's smooth and face
give him the butter oh [ __ ] charge it
that was the most perfect throw ever see
no battery men nice blockage oh [ __ ] the
King begins huh Oh fart LM alright okay
I'm gonna find your parents
no he's calling no no honey oh god I
really need it this time Oh God
Oh God panic how dare you our God is
almost there Oh God
this is the worst thing that could
possibly happen
Oh 99 we're [ __ ]
it's ringing
oh [ __ ] I wasn't worthy oh yes okay I
don't know how to get mana seriously
number four oh damn
now now we get a mana potion okay so at
least now I know how to get it but I
didn't have any potions on me all right
we're ready to get in here
and save our friend damn you crude for
for gingers man that's not that's not
cool thanks for busting me out kid who
are you ginger didn't escape freckle
maniac oh well I'm heading to Cooper
Kiba see you there I guess
okay enough ginger [ __ ] I want to go
back to my Jewish blunt and my charm
tastes pain oh that's that's soakaway
but I want my my butt cheek my budget
gets my power all right I'm gonna have
to end this episode here I hope you bros
enjoyed watching I'm really glad you
were enjoying this series because I
really loved it and for me to do this
it's just amazing so live like you know
watching Bruce hits a sky Cumbre today
is a breakfast for you love you bro haha